joining me now is stephen miller former
senior adviser to president trump and
founder of america first legal stephen
i don't think people have made enough of
these executive orders from biden
seeking
in the way he can to try to federalize
elections what are we missing here about
this executive order specifically from
last march
well i think you're completely right it
was an executive order that got
relatively little attention at the time
using the full weight and might of the
federal government agency by agency to
push mail-in voting
everywhere they can using every tool and
resource they can and so in other words
they were trying to take the tactics
used by mark zuckerberg
to privatize our elections to establish
these anonymous drop boxes where we've
now seen what have been called mules or
vote traffickers putting in these
massive numbers of ballots unverified
anonymous
unknown
and now they're trying to take that and
move it into every single part of the
country they can that would mean the end
of election security forever and in that
sense it would be a direct attack on
american democracy because nothing's
more fundamental to democracy than the
security and the sanctity of the
citizens vote
well i think it's particularly
disturbing in that
executive order that section i
highlighted
about empowering third-party
organizations
yes yes to
push the uh the filling out of the
ballots and the ballot registration
application
um and so forth and explaining to people
what they need to know a supposedly
nonpartisan
institution or organization doing that i
found that to be very disturbing well
that was exactly that was exactly the
scheme that mark zuckerberg
pulled off in the 2020 election where he
spent over 400 million dollars
working to administer the elections in
key districts that had a democrat lien
in swing states and even though it was
done under the auspices of being quote
non-partisan in other words what is
known as a 501c3
it was explicitly partisan it was
targeted the voter registration and
engagement and dropbox efforts were all
targeted in
key democrat strongholds in swing
states and so they're clearly trying to
use that exact same system that mark
zuckerberg used
and entrench it even
further and i will say that republicans
in congress
must must subpoena mark zuckerberg to
get to the bottom of this in
the next congress so they have the
majority now the media doing everything
they can to undermine confidence in our
election over this voter integrity law
uh fakery that they're pulling here's
katy k
we're in a moment where it's not just
potentially republicans who aren't going
to trust the democratic system if we
have a 2024 election where there's been
so much
change so many changes to the voting
laws democrats won't believe the system
either and this is exactly what
xi jinping what vladimir putin
what victor orban is exactly what they
want
i i mean i love how she tries to tie in
the autocrats yes when those same people
are protecting china as i said in the
angle at every turn they work to protect
china
well i mean first of all it's well known
that vladimir putin is the mastermind
behind the destiny plan of voter id uh
he's the one who actually invented the
driver's license i'm told i mean the
whole notion that there is anything
improper
about asking people to present an id
before they vote this is the most basic
minimum baseline for election security
every single voter should not only have
to present an id but they should also
have to demonstrate to be a lawfully
registered voter that they're a citizen
of the country you talk about foreign
interference in our elections yeah how
is it possible that we don't even verify
citizenship
stephen great to see you tonight thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else